ils ont exploré le moindre recoin fait
des photos compter les chats
l'évaluation sanitaire a pris du temps
qui a passé en revue les 39 félin
recensés avec la pleine et entière
collaboration d'un propriétaire encore
tout surpris de faire l'objet de tant de
soupçons j'en prends choix ils sont
assurés d'une nourriture régulière en
quantité suffisante
ils ont de l'eau il ouvre à ce niveau là
et j'ai pas de problème
il sera aussi ré également de soins
médicaux des mots étayés par des faits
la conclusion s'impose dès lors aux
agents dépêchés sur place
il n'y a pas matière à saisir des
animaux il n'y a pas de maltraitance
il n'y a pas de souffrance animale
il y a même je dirais une très grande
attention de la part de monsieur daury à
l'égard de ses chats la vraie difficulté
c'est la gestion donc de la densité et
de la reproduction
les propriétaires sera donc mis en
demeure de stériliser et d'identifier
ces chats sous six mois
quant à la congélation des animaux morts
de mort naturelle
la congélation c'est pour ne pas se
séparer de ses chats ce n'est pas une
infraction
c'est presque touchant c'est presque
touchant effectivement oui tout à fait
c'est tout à fait ça le propriétaire
aurait donc pêché par excès d'amour trop
de coeur trop de chats auquel il
consacré l'essentiel de sa retraite mais
dont il tire toute sa raison de vivre
il y en a quelques-uns qui vaut veux
qu'ils vont me monte sur les épaules ils
vont faire des petits mamour comme ça
ils vont me lécher ils vont me lécher
les cheveux parce qu'il ya une odeur
quand même mais quand même ils aiment
leur maître his or her avec moi qu'on me
laisse vivre ma passion jusqu'à la fin
de mes jours
c'est tout ce que
la régularisation de sa prolifique
compagnie aura bien sûr un coût auquel
il dit vouloir faire face
le prix de la tranquillité de ses vieux
jours bousculé par une alerte sans doute
un peu vite lancé par la spa